thanks to audible for keeping legal
eagle in the air
research suggests that PTSD can be
triggered by a new stressors like losing
your family I need to get to work on the
opening statement but we need to be sure
Castle will get on board with this ah
I'll try
so have they not spoken to their client
before pro tip if trial is tomorrow you
really really really need to talk to
your client beforehand to know what your
defenses are going to be hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a lawyer
today we are covering the trial of frank
castle from Marvel's daredevil we've
been on a bit of a Marvel tear here on
this channel but before I leave the
marvel legal Cinematic Universe at least
for a little while I wanted to make sure
that I covered this highly requested
seen from daredevil where Frank castle
is put on trial for all of the murders
that he has committed and he is being
defended
spoiler alert by Matt Murdock who is
also daredevil on the side lawyers got
to have the side hustle I guess as
always be sure to leave your objections
in the comments which all either sustain
or overrule and stick around until the
end of the video where i give the trial
of frank castle from daredevil a grade
for legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in to the trial of Frank
Castle on daredevil
[Music]
all right this is kind of an interesting
scene that you don't see all that often
in legal procedurals it takes a long
time to get a defendant out of the
lock-up to be ready for a court
appearance and often if court
appearances are at 8:00 or 9:00 a.m.
then you might have to wake up at 3 or 4
o'clock in the morning and be
transported from the jail over to the
courthouse where your hearing is going
to take place so we actually saw this in
the Paul Manafort trial not too long ago
where he waived his right to appear in
person so he wouldn't have to go through
all the rigmarole of getting woken up
being transported which can take hours
from the jail to the courthouse and only
to have some sort of procedural hearing
take place and that's why often you'll
see defendants waive their right to
appear in court and just let the lawyers
take care of it unless it's really
important that the defendant be there
like the trial is starting I get my
hands on the worthless intern who
organized these files I'm sure that
intern is just following the DA's orders
officially sabotage that's a bad trick
we got bigger problems like blocking a
defense but not and we'll still our best
bet what's that the insanity plea oh god
we need to buy a not guilty verdict high
school debate team could prove that
Cassell did it okay a couple problems
here number one is that an insanity plea
is very very unlikely to work the other
problem is that New York actually does
not follow the McNaughton rule new york
follows a modified version of the model
Penal Code the model Penal Code is a
theoretical rubric for potential
criminal laws that was created by a
bunch of American scholars who saw that
there were some issues with some of the
antiquated laws that the United States
had at the time and so they put together
what they thought would be a model Penal
Code for the country and New York
adopted a version of the test that's
laid out by the model Penal Code the New
York law requires that a defendant true
by a preponderance of the evidence
because it's an affirmative defense that
at the time that the defendant committed
a crime that he or she lacked
substantial capacity to know either one
the nature and consequences of such
conduct or two that such conduct was
actually wrong the defendant can prove
either prong and meet the requirements
of the insanity defense but they have to
prove that by a preponderance of the
evidence so it's up to the defendant to
prove their insanity defense
now preponderance the evidence is
generally the standard that we use in
civil law it just means more likely than
not so if you had both sides on scale
the side that had slightly more weight
than the other one that is a
preponderance of the evidence so it can
be 51 percent that's enough to tip the
scales in your favor if you are the
defendant in a criminal case you want
the prosecution to have all of the
burden and they have to prove all of the
elements of their case beyond a
reasonable doubt which is a much much
higher standard than preponderance of
the evidence so that's the second issue
with Matt and foggy deciding on whether
to make a McNaughton defense in this
case it doesn't work in New York okay
and either way we need an opening
statement tomorrow like I can open with
PTSD as a mitigating factor focus on
Castle time at war so you think the war
is maybe what Frank what he is our only
goal is to reduce the charges and set
precedent counsel made a lot of enemies
all right if he goes into general
population he's as good as dead when
he's getting somewhere safe where he can
get help and citing PTSD you could do
that let me know must know what's a cast
I saw over there but research suggests
that PTSD can be triggered by new
stressors like losing your family I have
to get to work on the opening statement
but we need to be sure Castle will get
on board with this ah I'll try so have
they not spoken to their client before
pro tip if trial is tomorrow you really
really really need to talk to your
client beforehand to know what your
defenses are going to be all rise
Court is now in session okay looks like
a pretty reasonable affects him live in
New York courthouse indictment number
one nine eight six four four four seven
the People vs Frank Castle be seated
looks like you're a man down ladies and
gentlemen of the jury the defendant has
been indicted for several serious crimes
but I'm instructing you as a point of
law College streams damn that was
supposed to deliver everything not me
this race are the people ready to begin
opening statements I like that the judge
has already started instructing the jury
here because so much of what happens in
an actual trial is really opaque to
members of the jury and so the judge
always is trying to do his or her best
to hold the hand of the jury to make
sure that they understand what's going
on and I don't prejudge anyone just
because they happen to be you know
accused of some crime here now it's odd
that Frank Castle is still in his orange
jumpsuit and he is shackled to the table
if you were worried that he was prone to
violence and was a threat to someone
that would be a reason to actually keep
him in Chains but even under those
circumstances you would still probably
let him wear a suit to court so that he
can at least look semi respectable and
not like an actual criminal at that
point ladies and gentlemen of the jury
Frank Castle brutally tortured and
murdered 30 people 30 that we know of oh
man it's very argumentative for an
opening statement acted as judge jury
and most violent executioner she's way
too close to the jury did not ask for
permission and er the well and you will
hear that the defendants victims were
criminals but the victims are not on
trial here today and justice does not
belong in the hands of a man like Frank
Castle this isn't the Wild West justice
is served here in a court of law
and it is up to each of you to take back
the city from lawless vigilantes yeah
this is a pretty improper
putting statement an opening statement
is your opportunity to give the jury a
preview of what your case is going to
show it's your opportunity to establish
a theme but mostly it's not for argument
it is for an opening statement to to
show what you intend to prove and to set
the the guidelines at the same time
you're not allowed to overly personalize
the jury and make the jury overly
emotional especially in a capital murder
case like this the defense should really
be objecting here because it's it's
pretty improper mr. Nelson are you
prepared to make your opening statement
she's good
no no she's not mr. Nelson mr. Nelson
are you reserving the right to make your
statement at a later time
ooh that's super cool yeah okay so what
the judge asked there is a really
interesting piece of trial procedure
that actually does exist in the real
world the defense has the option to
reserve their opening statement for the
start of their case in chief and if at
the end of the prosecution's case they
have not at least shown beyond a
reasonable doubt that the person being
accused is guilty then they have
effectively failed and you can move for
what's called a directed verdict or a
jnop which stops the trial right there
because the the prosecution didn't meet
their burden now you are allowed to
reserve your opening statement so that
you can say that okay well if the
prosecution has met their burden in the
first instance now we're going to do our
best to take the ball from our side of
the court and throw it back to the
prosecution and at that point you can
lay out what your entire case is going
to be in your own opening statement
there are strategic reasons why you
would do this number one if you don't
have a particularly good case you might
reserve your opening statement to a
later time if you feel like the
prosecution is really not going to be
able to meet their burden you might
reserve your statement for later to put
all of the focus on the prosecution's
case and given that lead trial counsel
hasn't shown up reserving your opening
statement is probably a good way to go
here so your 19
standing in hot sand Sun burning down
noise yelling gunfire the only thing
that you know for sure is that you're
surrounded by an enemy that wants you
dead I don't know that this is
necessarily argumentative I mean he's
sort of talking about facts and if he'd
preface this by saying that the evidence
will show this this and this you could
probably get away with it the problem is
that in a case like this the last thing
that you would want to do is bring in
character evidence I don't think that
number one that's relevant and number
two when you do that it opens the
floodgate and man the prosecution would
just bring in witness after witness
showing Frank castles bad characters so
I think they're some big strategic
problems with fog ease opening statement
here but you do it you endure it why
because you have orders and you have a
duty what does that have to do with
anything life doesn't end here you have
people you love waiting at home because
aside from being a decorated marine the
man before you it's a good husband and
an excellent father okay so he's going
hard into the good character right now
returned from the hell of war wanting
nothing more than to pick up his life
but his wife young son and daughter were
brutally murdered by criminals and no
one not the police and certainly not the
District Attorney stepped up to make it
right see Frank Castle never came home
he just traded in one war zone for
another
it's trial uh Matt Murdoch shows up whoo
hey too late it's about the failure of
the justice system and how one man Frank
Castle is being used as a pawn to cover
up that system's mistakes huh so that's
not a great theme I mean it's okay you
want to focus on the government's burden
to prove their case beyond a reasonable
doubt but Fogg he hasn't given the jury
something to hang their hat on if you
can rely on good character and that's
all you have then that's all you have so
you go after Frank's good character and
you say that that's a mitigating
circumstance but yeah I don't think it's
a very good opening statement look I
made a mistake and I feel terrible about
it before I called someone drove a
statement you did great it was amazing
okay so if you are lead trial counsel in
a capital murder case I think missing
the opening statement that you were
supposed to give is probably grounds for
malpractice
I wonder if daredevil Matt Murdock is
canonically a good lawyer in the comics
you know what lovely get an expert on
this hey Matt can you help out a sec
thanks Devin as a longtime daredevil fan
and fellow Matt myself I feel uniquely
qualified to say that daredevil should
be one of if not the greatest fictional
lawyers of all time he's very
intelligent graduated from Columbia Law
School he's also an amazing detective
and most notably the accident that
blinded Matt as a child gave him
heightened senses one of which is super
hearing which he's able to use to his
advantage during trials Matt can hear a
heartbeat from across a room which he
uses kind of like a human lie detector
he can tell if a juror is on his side
and potentially change his argument to
win more support he can also tell if a
witness is lying or telling the truth
he's essentially psychic however the
biggest obstacle between Matt and legal
success is frequently Matt himself he
has a strong sense of Catholic guilts
that often forces him to take on lost
causes that he can't win also Matt's
double life as daredevil forces him to
split his time between being a lawyer
and a vigilante which in some cases has
forced him to lose clients and even lose
cases in conclusion based off the comics
you take into account his intelligence
and his super-hearing Matt Murdock
should be one of if not the best
fictional lawyers of all time thanks Dan
doh I guess now I know never to hire
Matt Murdock Walter Gregory temper how
long have you been medical examiner for
the city of New York
14 years give or take and how many death
certificates would you estimate you find
in that time huh uh I don't it's
probably in the tens of thousands
objection your honor
leading the witness oh my god
such a stupid objection
cross-examination is supposed to be all
leading questions and on top of that
this would be a really really softball
question for a medical examiner a
medical examiner testifies a lot I mean
part of their job is to testify in these
kind of criminal cases so they're gonna
have a lot of experience especially
someone who has been the medical
examiner of the city of New York for 14
years so he would have a ballpark figure
for the number of death certificates
that he signed a lot because that's a
questions going to come up in
cross-examination like this where you're
allowed to lead the witness I have
something I need to say doctor your
honor I'm sorry but I have to on the
record I need to say something about
what I did clear the gallery
all jory members please exit back to the
deliberation room why are they taking
frank castle out he's the defendant he
definitely gets to stay at this point
Your Honor I believe the defense intends
to distract the jury and make this case
about some impossible to prove
conspiracy theories possible to prove
you Remy just confirmed that he doctored
the autopsy video yeah Murdock is
totally ur height there that you're
forgetting anything to do with this
our firm probably knows you who sent
those goons I've heard enough it's clear
to me that whatever dr. temper may know
about these autopsy reports has been
tainted by threats made by person or
persons unknown then the defense asks
for a mistrial not on your life mr.
Nelson what not convinced these
documents whatever they may be are even
relevant to this trial I'm striking the
doctors entire testimony and instructing
the jurors to disregard anything they
may have heard okay a couple of
different things going on here the judge
is probably right that the medical
examiner's testimony about Frank's
family is not relevant that being said
in this particular trial this is the
medical examiner that not only examined
Frank's family and conducted the
autopsies on Frank's family but he also
conducted the autopsies on all of the
victims the medical examiner has been
testifying for probably days I mean I
know they're showing it as a matter of
hours but this kind of testimony over
the deaths of 17 people plus Frank's
family that's gonna take days and it's
going to be a very very important
witness for the state it's incredibly
unfair I would say clearly prejudicial
for the state to be able to show the
jury the testimony of this medical
examiner and then prevent the defense
from being able to cross-examine the
medical examiner you are
constitutionally allowed to face your
accusers and it's crazy for the judge
not to declare a mistrial right now the
jury has been tainted you can't unring
that Bell and there's no way to go
forward I think if you were the
prosecution you'd be pissed too
because without the medical examiner's
testimony I'm not sure how you prove up
your case I wonder if you could tell us
how lieutenant Frank
so one the Navy Cross due to the nature
of that mission you'll have to
understand that precise circumstances
are classified about the part that's not
lieutenant frank castle was part of a
small team was conducting a closed
target reconnaissance in the vicinity of
the Hindukush mission became compromised
taking enemy contact on three sides
antenna caster wanted to abort said the
mission was a bust
while the plug would save lives officer
in charge said no I feel like this is
that scene out of airplane where the the
wife is asking Stryker about what he's
going to to do and he says my orders
came through my squadron ships out
tomorrow were bombing the storage depots
a daiquiri at 1800 hours we're coming in
from the north below their radar and she
says
I can't tell you that it's classified
precise circumstances are classified it
really seems like this character has
just talked about a whole bunch of
classified information and there can't
possibly be any classified information
left that he hasn't already divulged to
the jury my father served in Vietnam do
you know what he told me about medals no
ma'am he said the only people who truly
know what happened are the ones that
were there he told a nice story colonel
but how can we know that it happened the
way you described perhaps I wasn't clear
I was there man that officer that didn't
listen to Frank got his men trapped
you're looking at him oh this is a great
dramatic seed I mean regardless of legal
accuracy I just I love the turn around
here this is a great example of the
legal truism that you do not ask
questions on cross-examination that you
don't already know the answer to are you
aware that Frank castles wife son and
daughter were all murdered right in
front of him when he sustained the brain
injury in question an injury which you
say keeps him in a perpetual state of
mental and emotional chaos I am yes with
that in mind would you say that Frank
castles mental state satisfies the
definition of extreme emotional
disturbance objection calls for
conclusion your honor dr. Lee is an
expert on the brain he is qualified to
an opinion and said opinion is not only
relevant but imperative to the case okay
so this is a really interesting
objection here I think they're a little
confused on the terminology but this
kind of objection makes sense so you are
allowed to call experts and experts are
allowed to opine in a way that lay
witnesses are not allowed to opine when
they testify that's really the whole
point of an expert that being said
generally speaking witnesses are not
allowed to opine as to what we call the
ultimate issue in the case so you can't
ask a witness do you think the defendant
is guilty
well the guilt is one of the ultimate
issues in a case and if you are arguing
insanity for example you can't say does
that mean that
the defendant is actually insane for the
purposes of the insanity plea because
that's the ultimate issue and only the
jury is able to design the ultimate
issues if emotional disturbance is an
ultimate issue for the Trier of fact
then it would be improper for the expert
to opine but if emotional disturbance is
a neurological term that is sort of a
stepping stone for whatever legal issue
that they are trying to prove then it
would be okay for this neurologist to
make that testimony mr. Castleman you've
been charged with multiple capital
crimes been called a killer incapable of
empathy or remorse so I hear Frank may I
call you Frank yeah it's good you want
to humanize your defendant Frank we've
heard a lot about neuro chemistry in
psychology and all things unfolding
scientifically and otherwise inside your
brain I just have one question I want to
ask I hate it when people say they have
one question because it's never just one
question what happened that day the day
your family was so tragically killed
it's okay Frank
I understand it's difficult do you do
you understand cuz I don't think you
understand [ __ ] like permission to treat
the witness as hostile your honor okay
so this is actually a good example of
when you can actually treat a witness as
hostile it's a request that's made in
legal dramas all the time but they
usually get it wrong here they they
basically get it right all it means to
treat a witness as hostile is to be able
to ask them leading questions yes it is
a witness that you have provided but
they're being obstreperous in a way that
they are not answering open-ended non
leading questions so you ask permission
from the judge to ask leading questions
that would normally not be allowed on
direct examination now that being said
it's always always risky to put a
criminal defendant on the stand when
your witness stops complying with your
softball questions you know you're in
the danger zone and you really just have
to cut your losses to tell you exactly
what kind of man you are no you're not
allowed to do that you you still have to
ask questions you're the kind of man
this city needs because ladies and
gentlemen of the jury we all know this
city needs help
needs it now not tomorrow not next week
not when the day comes when the
corruption that Wilson Fisk left in his
wake is yes objection arguments this
city's been sick
and the cops they can't fix it alone
they need we all need men and women is
this is totally improper how to present
him wrong their lives so that we can
walk safer at night in our own
neighborhoods the ones our esteemed
District Attorney here is trying so hard
to destroy New York needs these people
we need it's hard for me to even watch
this because it's so cringe-inducing oh
okay
and now we're gonna we're gonna applaud
the speech that's being made in the
middle of a direct examination the judge
would not allow this the prosecution
would be objecting Your Honor can you
say something you may you know those
people ones that put down the people I
killed I want you to know that I'd do it
all again this is a circus all right
used to charade it's an act
am I ain't crazy and that ladies and
gentlemen is why you don't put a
defendant on the stand unless you
absolutely have to bad idea okay
[Music]
that was the trial of Frank Castle in
Marvel's daredevil a lot of good stuff a
lot of bad stuff definitely interesting
to watch since I haven't seen it in a
while on the plus side they have some
really interesting arguments they
treated a witness as hostile in the
correct way they have some good
back-and-forth about the different
burdens that are required whether you're
the defense of the prosecution it's an
interesting expert testimony on the
other hand man you can't make a speech
in the middle of an examination that's
insane there's so much procedurally
going wrong this trial would have taken
months and they're really just
shortening it for dramatic effect
obviously so overall I give the trial of
Frank Castle a solid see it's okay
needs some work but it's entertaining
all right I get the hint
you know one way that Matt Murdock is
able to accomplish so much in so little
time is by listening to audiobooks
lately I've been listening to Marvel
Comics the untold story on audible it's
an amazing behind-the-scenes chronicle
of one of the most extraordinary beloved
and dominant pop cultural entities in
American history Marvel Comics it's the
fascinating story of how Marvel went
from bankruptcy to cultural juggernaut
pun intended it incorporates hundreds of
interviews with people like Stan Lee
Jack Kirby and all of those people that
work behind the scenes to create what
Marvel Comics is today it even answers
some of the questions you never knew you
had like whose dumb idea was it to give
a spider-man a spider mobile in the 70s
why did Captain America Iron Man and
Submariner suddenly all get solo titles
in 1968 and why was Secret Wars such a
terribly written story audible is giving
legal eagles like you a free 30-day
trial with two free originals to go with
it so you too can listen to marvel the
untold story all you need to do is go to
audible.com slash legal eagle or text
legal eagle - 500 500 you can download
any audio book of your choosing and get
two originals free clicking on the link
really helps out this channel so check
out Marvel the untold story on audible
just head over to audible.com slash
legal legal text legal eagle - 500 500
or just click the link in the
description do you agree with my grade
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with my other real lawyer reactions
where I will see you in court